hi I'm Michael Italy and I'm Andrew
Stein a Kurd we're going to be talking
about food in the Wolfram language
oh I'm Andrew Stein rocker and I'm gonna
be talking about food and nutrition and
Wolfram language um ah so just jump
ahead here I love let's see here
so if you've seen some of my talks
previously I've been doing food and
nutrition for a couple years I'm on
Wolfram language and various sorts of
things I'm on my colleague Micah has
been working on a couple things with me
with stuff related to that and so I'll
give you a quick overview of a blog he
did and then some new Wolfram Alpha
output that we've that we've been
working on as well as a nice way to
visualize the ontology that we've
created over the past couple of years as
well as an open source meal tracker that
I've been working on so if you need
information on the previous talks or
need some more background and how this
all works here's a lot of links that are
helpful feel free to download the
notebook it should be available on the
conference website or passable and if
not you can always ask me for some of
these resources afterwards if you'd like
um so Micah wrote a blog post last year
around Christmastime about computational
gastronomy and one of the things he did
in that blog was leverage on data drop
and the Wolfram cloud with a form
function to be able to create a
Christmas dinner survey and so just with
a couple lines of code he was able to
set up a survey that he could send to
his family members so that they could
say whether or not they were going to be
able to make it and whether or not they
needed dietary restrictions and that
sort of thing um uh so that he could
plan what meal he needed to make there
was a neat use of our technology to do
that another neat thing that he looked
at was um European holiday foods and so
he made this neat little em'ly map where
you can actually have tooltips of all of
these different foods where you can see
nice some images and and he used um
dominant colors to be able to pick out
the nice colors to go along with these
sorts of things with that sort of stuff
another thing that he's helped curate is
a lot of ingredient substitutions if you
were how my talk last year you would
have seen some of this stuff so here
we've got some nice visualizations of
how it worked and he was able to use
some of that stuff when he was making
making Christmas dinner for his family
on so you can see there's some nice
stuff here
nice little mouse overs and things like
that to go with them and of course we
have a lot of obscure things to some not
so common substitutions as well that
he's gone through and curated so I think
we have I think on the scale of like
2,000 substitutions which are pretty
helpful when you're in the kitchen
trying to keep track of things another
interesting thing that we've added
lately is cooking times and he was able
to use those as well so for example here
just by using a little bit of Dominic
color work you can make a nice plot to
be able to see the difference between
cooking times of various different foods
so like yours
broccoli rabe for example and um you
know corn for example and and bacon and
so with a little bit of color changes
you can actually get these cooking times
visualized pretty easily
um so moving on from Micah's blog we can
talk about the new Wolfram Alpha put
that I've been working on and so in the
current and previous versions of Wolfram
Alpha output for foods we've added about
10 times as many foods if you've been to
my talks last year you've you've seen
that we've had in quite a few of these
so now we're almost at about 150,000
foods which is dramatically larger than
the previous system that way and one of
the things that we've done with this new
output is that we've made it a little
more visually appealing the previous one
has a lot of tables involved and
although tables are useful they're not
exactly the most visually appealing
sorts of things on so in order to
convert some of those things into
visualizations it makes it easier to
digest the information that's there for
example including compass plots you know
bar charts and pie charts as well one of
the neat things that we've added is
nutrition labels for the nutrition
labels we've added ranges so with the
click of the button you can actually see
the ranges the present normally of
course on packages you don't see ranges
on the nutrition labels and I think by
law they don't really like it when you
do that but it is really handy
information to see when you actually
look into it that way and if you've seen
my talks before I've talked a lot about
them using compass plots to quickly
visualize lots and lots of data we also
have that available on the website
- and with a with this pulldown menu you
can actually select them different
nutrient groups and see everything that
way and you can add and remove things
from their sort of interactively I'm not
to see things that way and comparisons
are nice and tables but sometimes it's
nice to see visually so we've also added
this Nutrition distribution pod which
allows them for seeing the the food that
you have in question like you're at
punched in saltine crackers and refried
beans and so you can see the
distributions for those specific foods
but you can also see them in comparison
to similar food types as well as all
food groups so you can actually see how
they fit in comparatively to each other
or by themselves and then also with the
individual food types that are similar
so for example here you can see that in
terms of carbohydrates actually saltine
crackers are actually much higher than
most of the other ones online and that
can that have that food type as well I'm
going a little further
like I've said we still have some tables
we didn't get rid of all of them so for
example we have one for a caloric
equivalent x or basically how long it
takes to burn off the calories or fat of
a given food so here I've got one for
Big Mac so you can see that it takes
some on the scale of seven hours to
sleep it off or you could just go
swimming for like a half hour online
instead if you were doing you know some
vigorous swimming that sort of thing as
well and so in the first version it'll
be a little bit limited to those sorts
of things and it covers most of the pods
that we had in the previous one but if
you've seen my talks before a lot of
things a lot of data that we have that
wasn't in the previous one includes you
know packaged food ingredients and so
we're working on getting that set up
quickly too so hopefully immediately
after the next release the next thing
that will hopefully get is I'm a
packaged food ingredients available as
an example here with some of these as
you can see I'm going a little further
with that you can also see dietary
restrictions and so we can give a lot of
detailed information on how that's
broken down and a nice easy to digest
visualization I'll see you can actually
see what's what's happening there fairly
easily
so uh you
in the you know we have a lot of
information in the in this new ontology
and so kind of visualizing it and
keeping track of it's kind of hard to do
so um in order to do it a little more
easily what we can do is create a graph
out of it so I made a website that
actually shows this ontology graph
fairly easily just by going through some
of the stuff so if you want to go to
this URL you can ah ah there's a nice
little website that kind of describes
everything and shows it online better
detail on the website you know there's
larger images and that sort of thing and
be sure to go downstairs we have a
printout of it that's a nice and big so
you can take a look at things that way
as well and there's also larger images
and that sort of thing on the website as
well if you're interested in it I can
talk a little bit about that um the way
I created it was I more or less used
entity value open/close which gives all
the different types and then I just
yanked out the ones that have food in
the name and from there I just use
entity property class to be able to pull
out specific metadata for all the
properties and so they all have labels
you know output types definitions
you know units and and physical
quantities and that sort of thing and
from from that information you can
connect the things using some processing
stuff but more or less in a nutshell
what you can do is you connect on you
you go through all the properties and
basically for every type there's a
property and the property has an output
type and the output type either points
to another entity type or a basic data
type like a number or an association or
something like that and you can create a
graph kind of like this but um when when
you actually do it it's awfully messy
and in order to clean it up a little bit
you can get rid of a few things and kind
of simplify it a bit more and you end up
with a structure more like this the
details are in the notebooks if you're
interested in seeing those and from
there really all you have to do is just
to find some useful node groups pass it
in to community graph plot add some
colors some I know a minor styling type
tweaks and then before you know it
you've got a really nice looking graph
of the ontology and so from there I'm
you know hosting it onto a website is
actually fairly straightforward the
amount of code is actually pretty small
I can get something on the scale of like
150 lines of code or something like that
for the web
by itself the notebooks on how to create
the thing are actually a little bit more
intense than that but the website itself
is fairly straightforward and here I've
got a git repository on github if
anyone's interested in seeing how to do
it and that sort of thing and another
thing that I've worked on I think last
year we had a few people that were
really interested in seeing like a meal
tracking sort of application and so they
asked how to do it and that sort of
thing and so I tried to give some advice
on how to do it and it turns out it's a
little complicated so I went to sip went
through and figured out how to do it and
created an open-source meal tracker that
some easy to deploy it should be
straightforward and it's open and
accessible for anyone to edit and that
sort of thing as well so this is just a
link to the github page there's
instructions on there I'd be more than
happy to talk to anybody interested in
actually deploying it for themselves and
and also editing this stuff but I'll
quickly go over some of the features it
has if you've been to my talks in the
past you know we've added a lot of
features including natural language
input you know UPC lookups you know
barcode scanning and that sort of stuff
the website leverages all of these
technologies so that it makes it really
easy to add foods relatively painlessly
so you can just enter a food name and it
will go find that food using interpreter
and then you can look up serving sizes
for it with the click of a button you
can add all that stuff same with
entering codes for you PCs or PL use or
even just scanning barcode you can look
all that stuff up fairly straightforward
and once you do that since it's tied
into our food ontology you can actually
pull out all the nutrition information
there and if it's slightly different for
your specific food you can change that
and you can also manually edit the thing
like you have a food that we don't have
or something like that and from there
you can create meals just by grouping
these foods together and setting meal
types for them as well and then once
you've done that you can actually set up
serving sizes for them which is really
handy and useful that way to be able to
specify it more precisely and then once
you've added all those foods it's fairly
straightforward all you have to do is
select a food from a drop-down and
select a meal from a drop-down menu
change the servings if you need and the
time and that sort of thing and
hit a button and then it will log it and
if you need to change anything for the
one instance where you use you know a
little more of one ingredient than
another you can change that right there
on the spot
um and so with that you can actually
view the history in in various ways
including you know radar plots which are
similar to the the compass plots are
just a more open source version since we
can't really do that otherwise and a
nice time series so you can actually see
when when you actually hit the goal and
when maybe you need to stop beating for
the day if you there surpassed your goal
or something like that and with that too
since it's all stored on in a nice
computable format you can actually do
all kinds of neat analysis on just
customize it to whatever you're looking
for so for example I just made radar
plots of all the different nutrients and
and for various meals that I've done and
aggregated them together so then the top
row is all medians and the bottom rows
all means and then you can kind of see
that you know I get enough vitamin C in
the morning you know that sort of thing
but it's probably a little more helpful
to look at it on a day basis or you can
see I definitely get enough vitamin C
and protein but I don't get very much
iron so I probably should change my diet
crown so I get a little more iron or
something but it's nice to at least see
that kind of information and learn from
them that what you might be able to uh
improve your diet or something like that
there are some advanced features with
this that are really handy to have like
I hooked up the ability to set up
reminders because it's it's actually
kind of painful if anyone's tried to log
their meals when they eat or one of the
most painful things is remembering to
log it and so one way to remember to do
that it's like set up scheduled tasks in
the cloud that will actually send you
emails or text messages and you can
configure them at a certain time of day
to send it to you so as an example I get
a text message on log that I can click
on and that'll take me to the link where
I can actually choose what food that I
need to put in there just proven to be
pretty handy and the another advanced
feature that we had some people talk
about before was having real
recommendations and these meal
recommendations um can be done just by
doing a fairly simple I guess if you
really know what's going on linear
programming work and so I'm not an
expert on linear
but Michael trot and Dan McDonald helped
me write awesome code that does it
pretty well actually
and it's open source so you can see how
it works you can tweak it you can
improve it and that sort of thing too
but the idea is you can select the meal
types that you're interested in you can
select the nutrients that you want to
match to and you can adjust the
parameter if you need to based on how
how well it fits and that sort of thing
online and then it'll produce some
suggestions for you and then from there
you can keep hitting the button and
there's a little bit of randomness to it
so it'll help you pick a decent one a
lot if you don't like those choices that
it gives you from there there's some
nice buttons on there there's a log
button that you can click on and we'll
double-check with you it'll make a
little window come up in the browser and
check that that is indeed what you want
to do and with a click of a button
that'll actually log it straightaway to
your history and that sort of thing for
the given amount and if you don't like
the amount that's there you can just hit
the edit button and we'll open in the
new tab and give you the ability to
change the UM the amount that you're
going to log for that which is um pretty
handy so that way you can still
customize it even if it is just um
automated in that way and so to talk a
little bit about the implementation
details real quick you know the history
side of it is all based on data drop and
so here's some nice useful information
if you haven't used data drop it's
actually really a really neat handy tool
to be able to block all kinds of
information I've got an example here
where I use it to log the gas mileage in
my car so I just punched the information
and with a simple web form and and the
the backend
um I use a Wolfram language entity store
which allows me to extend the entity
types that are already available in the
language so like the food and food type
entities that I've talked about in my
previous talks are all still a lot of
the properties and that sort of thing
are still available and so I use an
entity store for the foods and meals and
and my stuff to be able to extend them
and still leverage the same amount of
stuff there without too much trouble if
you're interested there's a nice talk
that Tony gave in 2016 that explains
that in better detail and of course
there's always the documentation for it
as well and with that I guess I will
stop there and I guess open the leopard
questions
[Applause]